when you say space time is doomed is it
the space is the is the is it the time
is it the very hard-coded specification
of four dimensions
uh
or are you specifically referring to the
kind of uh
perceptual domain that humans operate in
which is space-time you think like
there's a 3d
um
like our world is three-dimensional and
time progresses forward therefore three
dimensions plus one for d what uh what
what exactly do you mean by space time
what do you mean by space time is doomed
great great so this is by the way not my
quote this is from for example nema or
kanye hamed at the institute for
advanced study at princeton ed whitten
also there
david gross
nobel prize winner so this is not just
something the cognitive scientists this
is what the physicists were saying yeah
the physicists their space time uh
skeptics
we are they're saying that and i can say
exactly why
they think it's doomed but what they're
saying is that because your question was
what what aspect of space time what are
we talking about here it's both space
and time their union into space time as
an einstein's theory that's doomed
and
they're they're basically saying that
even quantum theory this is with neymar
connie ahmed especially so the
hilbert spaces will not be fundamental
either so that that
the notion of hilbert space which is
really critical to
quantum field theory quantum information
theory uh that's not going to figure in
the fundamental
new laws of physics so what they're
looking for is some new mathematical
structures beyond space-time
beyond
you know einstein's four-dimensional
space-time or
supersymmetric version
geometric algebra signature two comma
four kind of there are different ways
that you can represent it but they're
finding new structures and then by the
way they're succeeding now they're
finding they found something called the
amplitude this is nema and his
colleagues the
the cosmological polytope these are so
there are these like
polytopes these polyhedra in in
multi-dimensions generalizations of
simplices
that are coding
for
for example the scattering amplitudes of
processes in the large hadron collider
and other other colliders so they're
finding that if they let go space-time
completely
they're finding new ways of computing
these scattering amplitudes that turn
literally billions of terms into one
term
when you do it in space and time because
it's the wrong framework it's it's it's
just a user interface from that's not
from the evolutionary point of view it's
just user interface it's not a deep
insight into the nature of reality so
it's missing deep symmetry is something
called a dual conformal symmetry which
turns out to be true of the scattering
data but you can't see it in space-time
and it's making the comp the
computations way too complicated because
you're trying to compute all the loops
and findman diagrams and all the
finement integrals so see the feynman
approach to the scattering amplitudes is
trying to enforce two critical
properties of spacetime locality and
unitarity
and so by when you enforce those you get
all these loops and multiple you know
different levels of loops and for each
of those you have to add new terms to
your computation but when you do it
outside of space time
you don't have the notion of unitarity
you don't have the notion of locality
you have something deeper
and just capturing some symmetries that
are actually true of the data
and but then when you look at the
geometry of the facets of these
polytopes
then certain of them will code for
unitarity and locality so it actually
comes out of the structure of these deep
polytubes so what we're finding is
there's this whole new world now
beyond space-time
that is making explicit symmetries that
are true of the data that cannot be seen
in space-time and that is turning the
computations from billions of terms to
one or two or a handful of terms so
we're getting insights into symmetries
and we're and all of a sudden the math
is becoming simple because we're not
doing something silly we're not adding
up all these loops in space time we're
doing something far deeper but they
don't know what this world is about also
you know they're in an interesting
position
where we know that space time is doomed
and not i should probably tell you why
it's doomed what they're saying about
why it's jim but but they need a
flashlight to look beyond space-time
what what flashlight are we going to use
to look into the dark beyond space-time
because einstein's theory and quantum
theory can't tell us what's beyond them
all they can do is tell us that when you
put us together
time
is doomed at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters 10 to the minus 43 seconds
beyond that
space time doesn't even make sense it
just has no operational definition
so but it doesn't tell you what's beyond
and so they're just looking for deep
structures like guessing
it's really fun so these really
brilliant guys that generic brilliant
men and women who are doing this work
physicists are making guesses about
these structures informed guesses
because they're trying to ask well okay
what deeper structure could give us the
stuff that we're seeing in space time
but without certain commitments that we
have to make in space time like locality
and so they make these brilliant guesses
and of course most of the time you're
going to be wrong but once you get one
or two that start to pay off and then
you get some lucky breaks so they got a
lucky break back in 1986.
a couple of mathematicians named park
and taylor
took the scattering amplitude for
two gluons coming in at high energy and
four gluons going out at low energy so
that kind of scattering thing so it's
like apparently for people who are into
this that's sort of something that
happens so often you need to be able to
find it and get rid of those because you
already know about that and you need to
so you needed to compute them it was
billions of terms
and they couldn't do it even for the
supercomputers couldn't do that for the
many billions or millions of times per
second they needed to do it so they they
begged you know the experimentalists
begged the theorists please can you you
got it and so park and taylor took the
billions of terms hundreds of pages and
miraculous miraculously turned it into
nine
and then a little bit later they guessed
one term expression that turned out to
be equivalent so
billions of terms reduced to one term
the so-called famous park taylor formula
1986 and that was like okay where did
that come from what this is a pointer
into a deep realm
beyond space and time but but no one i
mean what can you do with it and they
thought maybe it was a one-off but then
other formulas started coming up and
then eventually neymar connie hamad and
his team found this thing called the
amplitude which really sort of captures
the whole
a big part of the whole bottle of wax
i'm sure they would say no there's
plenty more to do so so i won't say they
did it all by any means they're looking
at the cosmological polytope as well so
what's remarkable to me
is that
two pillars
of modern science
quantum field through with gravity
on the one hand
and evolution by natural selection on
the other
just in the last 20 years have very
clearly said
space time has had a good run
reductionism has been a fantastic
methodology so we had a great ontology
of space time a great methodology of
productionism
now it's time for a new trick
but now you need to go deeper and and
show but by the way this doesn't mean we
throw away everything we've done not by
a long shot
every new idea that we come up with
beyond space time must project precisely
into space time and it better give us
back everything that we know and love in
space time or generalizations
or it's not going to be taken seriously
and it shouldn't be so so we have a
strong constraint on whatever we're
going to do beyond space time it needs
to project into space time and whatever
this deeper theory is it may not itself
have evolution by natural selection this
may not be part of this deeper realm but
when we take the whatever that thing is
beyond space time and project it into
space time it has to look like evolution
by natural selection or it's wrong
so so that's
so that's a strong constraint on this
work so even the evolution
by natural selection and
quantum field theory
could be interfaces into something that
that doesn't look anything like like you
mentioned i mean it's interesting to
think that evolution might be
a very crappy interface into something
much deeper that's right they're both
telling us that the framework that
you've had can only go so far and it has
to stop and there's something beyond and
that framework the very framework that
is space and time itself now of course
evolution by natural selection is not
telling us uh about like einstein's
relativistic spaces that was another
question you asked a little bit earlier
it's telling us more about our
perceptual space and time
which um we have used as the basis for
creating first a newtonian space versus
time
as a mathematical extension of our
perceptions and then einstein then took
that and extended it even further so the
relationship between what evolution is
telling us what the physicists are
telling us is that in some sense the
newton and einstein
space-time
are formulated
as sort of
rigorous extensions of our perceptual
space
um making it mathematically rigorous and
laying out the symmetries that that they
find there so that's sort of the
relationship between them so it's the
perceptual space time that evolution is
telling us is just a user interface
effectively
and then the physicists are finding that
even the mathematical extension of that
into the einsteinian formulation
has to be as well
not the final story there's something
deeper
you